speaking out for the first time since
her son's acquittal wendy rittenhouse
recounting the tense moments waiting for
the verdicts and what she felt as they
were read alexis mcadams has the story
the rin house family tells me this has
all been an emotional roller coaster for
them kyle rittenhouse's mom talking to
me after that verdict before the family
left the state walking me through those
tense moments inside of this courtroom
as she found out her son wasn't going to
jail but coming home
it feels like a ton of bricks just
lifted off my shoulders for the first
time in a year and a half the
rittenhouse family breathing a sigh of
relief the teen now free we the jury
find the defendant kyle
kyle h rittenhouse not guilty
kyle rittenhouse dropping to his knees
acquitted of all charges
is there anyone who does not agree with
the verdicts as read he was on trial for
shooting three men killing two during
unrest in kenosha last summer you walk
into the courtroom there how were you
feeling when you heard that first not
guilty verdict once that verdict was
read
i was
i was
so relieved
for him
and
i started crying
my girls were crying
my just seeing kyle's
face and him just collapsing to the
floor
it was just overwhelming
the family knows not everyone believes
justice was served it's not about
winning or losing there was two people
that
did
passed away
and
families have to grieve during this
tearful testimony rittenhouse claiming
he fired in self-defense
he does have remorse
but talking to him now he would never
went down there if this ever happened
again he would never
once the verdict came down the family
rushing out of court due to safety
concerns
we're like running like down
hallways going through elevators what do
you see your son's life looking like
going forward from now
it's going to take time
you know
he wants to go to school he wants to
play with his dog milo
but it's going to be different for him
because there's going to be people out
there who wants to hurt him it's over
but
there's another chapter in our lives as
those cries for justice reform continue
to grow louder the written house family
tells me they're looking into pursuing
legal action
against people who they believe
slandered kyle rittenhouse arthel alexis
mcadams thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else